let me pull up this next story we have
from the post millennial
the post-millennial reports quote hate
has consequences trans group Mourns
death of Nashville trans Mass killer the
second and more complex tragedy is that
Aiden or Aubry Hale who felt he had no
other effective way to be seen than to
lash out by taking the life of others
this tweet says prepare to defend
yourself this weekend has already
provided us two Crystal Clear reasons
why we need to be prepared to defend
ourselves at a moment's notice against
Nazis and fascists
I don't want to read too much more into
this for obvious reasons because we're
talking about the lengths they're going
to advocate for more violence but that
post outright said this weekend get
ready and they're calling it defending
yourself this is what they do
the far left extremists go around
smashing windows and throwing fire bombs
and then when the police try to arrest
them they say they're allowed to defend
themselves they call the torching of
buildings and the beating of people in
the streets self-defense that's what
they're doing now with this I'm worried
about what's going to happen this
weekend so I would only say if you are
in the DC area exactly you need to be be
extra careful be prepared I don't know
I'm not going to give any advice me
personally if I was in DC I'd got it for
the weekend yeah no kidding but why not
you know Aaron the side of caution but
I'm going to tell you something this to
me the parallels are just it's
unbelievable if you look at the
juxtaposition just in between you know a
BLM and the whole
the Justified right to violence that
they assume and mischaracterize as
self-defense it's BLM it's antifa it's
all the same nonsense and they hide
behind their rhetoric and their rights
that they say that they have against
everyone else that they are allowed to
engage in violence that they are allowed
to loot to shoot to harm to injure to
destroy communities destroy property and
it's out of control and it's got to stop
and this is just another manifestation
of those movements now being expressed
in the trans movement you know another
manifestation of that behavior I think
is NATO or the way that NATO's been
behaving by putting military bases right
on the border of countries and then if
the countries get upset and invade
they're like you're the dude you you
can't put turrets in front of someone's
front door and expect that you're the
one that's under attack when they blow
up your turret like reasonable response
yeah they attacked your turret that was
attacking their space by encroaching on
it so like if you you can't that's just
this whole plank getting up in a cop's
face pushing or like you know getting
them to push you and then claiming
you're a victim you got up in the guy's
face if uh if any videos come out this
weekend I urge everyone to pay very
close attention to when that video
starts look for the editing that usually
comes to manipulate how uh how an
interaction started between law
enforcement that's uh always the first
thing you should pay attention to
because it speaks to their desire to uh
push you push you push you until you do
something back and then they have the
the weapon they need during Occupy Wall
Street there was a viral video that
showed several police officers striking
protesters and one cop was swinging his
baton like a baseball bat the occupiers
made a propaganda video where they
turned the Baton into a lightsaber to
make it funny and memeable and it was it
was clever and then someone later
released the full footage showing the
protesters attacking the police first
shaking a barricade trying to knock it
over and then one person hits the head
of the cop knocking his head off and
then the cop pulls the Baton sideways
starts pushing him back they start
hitting the cop back and then he starts
swinging the Baton they cut that out to
make it look like it's just the cops
swinging at these people and the funny
thing about all this is they started
saying because of my live streams you
can't edit this you can't fake it it's
raw it's live here's what they do they
would watch my live stream and then when
they did bad things they'd remain quiet
and then the moment the place attacked
they would take the link tweeted out
police attack innocent protesters
because anybody who tuned in at that
moment would only see the police
attacking protesters it's uh there's so
many ways to lie to people through all
like whether it's articles written like
Lie by structure where all the important
information comes in the last paragraph
of an article that's five paragraphs
long uh the in media whether it's audio
visual there's 10 000 more ways to lie
without actually lying have you seen
what Reuters reported about the shooting
former Christian School student shoots
up church and school oh yeah none of the
headlines none of the headlines had any
of the pertinent facts in any of the any
of the millions Lie by structure I would
like the way I'm shooting with this mass
murder by Audrey Hale like just to
remember just to leave the ideology out
of it if you can it's not about
transgenderism it's about a an adult
that's drugged up most likely drugged up
and like at least made to be crazy by
her parents or by her community or
whatever mental health issues and
perhaps exacerbated by our environment
or home runs or whatever we don't know
but we'd like to actually find out the
facts yes and don't blame transgender
people for this stupid woman's Behavior
like she's a psycho murderer that's a
person that's just a put that on Audrey
she did that nor should this be leading
to any legislation to take away gun
rights in my opinion because that's
going to be a trap people are going to
fall into because they're going to start
seeing this as a way to start taking
away gun rights and I don't think that's
the right thing to do I don't I mean was
she sorry I don't know how she got those
guns was she legally get those guns that
was the story there
that a number of guns were like
purchased in addition to the um two
rifles there was one handgun that she
had present on her person at the time
which engaged with the officers who
responded to the scene and there were
some reports that people are verifying
now as to whether or not there were
additional guns that were you know
procured but let me tell you something
like if you get a gun you get it legally
okay there are background checks there
is that the answer isn't to say oh we're
going to suspend you know rifles or guns
Etc it's like the people who pick them
up are the ones that are making these
choices that are doing this to engage in
that behavior how about actually caring
more about protecting soft targets and
children in schools because this keeps
happening because it is a vulnerable
asset for someone seeking to do harm and
take life they're not doing it other
places where they actually have armed
security and guards I mean look at every
single instance of this so when the
people say to me oh well you know this
is the problem because the person had
gone and they went in there and don't
you love children enough to actually
stop and ban these I love children
enough to have like retired military
veterans Etc retired law enforcement
come in that would like another job
after they retire go in there to protect
children bring in canine dogs Etc and
Harden the target then it makes it less
desirable I know this I was on the
shooting team officer-involved shooting
team at any time an officer had to
discharge a weapon and someone was
killed at the scene Etc to come and
investigate and clear the shooting so
I've seen it I've been there I've run
all the courses myself personally with
weapons a simulator for school shootings
for everything for preparedness for
officers to go in okay and that's what
we also need to do but unless we're
willing to make these tough decisions
and actually decide that children
shouldn't be collateral damage uh people
who choose to educate children should
not be allowed to be collateral damage
then you're going to see stuff like this
happen because evil like this is going
to follow the the path of least
resistance they will go into that school
they will try to take lives and there's
reports that this person went oh no but
about the there was somebody there with
security so then went back over you know
to this school like come on like figure
it out like look at the facts and stop
being like a hysterical you know uh
imbecile saying that the gun did it like
okay well how about people that get on a
train and they have knives or they have
whatever and they're causing harm and
stabbing people killing people like
that's what happens and I've seen it
over and over again for you know 20 plus
years of like investigating these cases
well you can try Banning knives like
they did in the UK but then people get
screwdrivers have you seen that great
picture of like the the UK cops you know
the American law enforcement they stand
in front of the thing of guns and drugs
and the UK cops are in front of a bunch
of like butter knives it's uh it's a
plastic scissors but here's the other
thing like right now they control the
narrative so well like if you go to
whether it's any celebrity that's
talking about this it immediately went
to gun control immediately like within
less than a half a day they were talking
about gun control and the The Narrative
has already shifted I remember somebody
did before like after Uvaldi talked
about uh what it would cost to get armed
security at every school in America and
it was like like five billion dollars or
something like that like right after we
spent 50 billion sent 50 billion to
Ukraine like it just proves to you like
who the hell they care about which is
not us so we got to secure you right is
that like one guard per building because
there's like 40 entrances in some of
these schools I think the the the math
that they did it was like three well it
was like three yeah like that's not even
an average salary of like I think three
is better than zero and harming the
teachers is one way to go or we can give
it to salinsky that's that's fine we'll
just give it to the list we're allowing
teachers to arm themselves well some
some schools have uh allowed that right
um I'm not so sure arming teachers is
the appropriate response I think
teachers should be allowed to be armed
but I think armed security makes the
most sense yeah but also there's plenty
of volunteers if you're just saying okay
this is gonna cost as many billions of
dollars it's just a very reflexive uh
response that I think is just um you
know sophomore
um it's not actually Smart in terms of
actually analyzing what the you know
economic costs might be you know versus
actually you know the loss of life but
these are the same people that say you
know it's okay to abort your baby after
it's born if you get what I'm saying
I've sat in those courtrooms too with Dr
Phil Gosselin the maniac out of
Philadelphia that was literally drowning
uh children babies in the toilet after
they were born alive so you know these
are the same people like you know
championing those causes it's it's never
too much if it's Ukraine if it's uh to
promote you know the murder of uh
innocent children and babies and you
know what too much money if we have to
actually protect our children you know
in schools and by the way like I said
the Educators there's Educators there
there was ahead of the school whether
someone who's like the janitor the
teacher the maintenance guy like human
beings like um devoting themselves my
mother was a teacher I've worked as a
teacher I've worked in some really crazy
like schools in San Francisco that had a
lot of like you know people that had
problems with like juvenile crime and
whatnot but you know there's some
schools in certain areas they got metal
detectors but like don't be the person
that sits there with your Abacus and
you're deciding and playing with human
beings lives and children's lives to me
that is that's cowardice when we're
talking about gun control it's a little
bit of an abacus speaking of Abacus I
have one right here
uh Tim you tweeted out yesterday should
we consider uh Banning people that have
hurting themselves I didn't suggest
anything I said should who have a mental
disorder with a higher associated with a
high rate of self-harm be barred from
owning guns I immediately clicked no
most people said yes
we're like yes it could be just an
emotional reaction to yesterday
is not what it is it's sort of an
emotional visceral reaction to what you
see and like getting tired emotionally
as a human being because you care of
seeing the same thing happen over and
over again and you want to come up with
a solution well so the the issue at hand
for a lot of people is that this
individual clearly was suffering from
some kind of mental distress what do you
think I I think the individual clearly
well it's a fact that the individual was
diagnosed and and I think that's what's
been reported with uh some with
depression anxiety uh gender dysphoria
things of that nature I don't know if I
care
um if someone has a mental illness I
don't I don't think second amendment
allows for you to borrow them from
wanting guns someone could be outright
schizophrenic
there would have to be a due process
adjudication and after due process your
rights can be curtailed right you can be
locked in a box if after due process you
can have your rights to a gun taken away
after due process so in that capacity
we have to recognize the challenge so a
lot of people said I don't think we
should ban guns in this way because they
will just pathologize conservative
thought and I'm like well yes they could
and then they will create a court system
with the judges they appoint to
adjudicate this and give you quote
unquote due process so it'll happen no
matter what with or without the Bill of
Rights
didn't they add masculinity to the DSM
recently So eventually TSM was that
really yeah DSM-5 access to diagnosis
like or something like that they added
toxic masculinity I could be
misremembering that I thought somebody
said that they added masculinity to the
to the DSM so maybe at one point anyone
who wants to own a gun anyways would be
seen as somehow masculine or toxically
masculine crazy so the story was in 2019
they called traditional masculine
masculinity harmful and face an upper
armor I don't know if it was added to
the DSM-5 or anything do they make the
dsm-6 wouldn't it yeah I don't um I'm
concerned you need the new version of
the update by the way that's the letters
on the access to diagnoses of the
different you know disorders that one
can have you know multiple
what was that the language that's the
language way that they get you to
remember it used to be toxic masculinity
now it's not that now it's just
traditional masculinity and eventually
it'll just be masculinity at all yeah
and then it'll just be men you can't
essentially a potential to harm yourself
is a reason to strip people's rights
because someone go online and be like
this world sucks man I hate myself and
then they'll be like oh go strip them of
his rights he's a David I'm not disagree
51.50. yeah but you can go online and
complain about how horrible things are
they're not but a judge has to sign off
on a warrant if you express something uh
if you CR you've created this uh if you
present a clear and imminent threat to
yourself or others right 51.50 taking
51.50 you then yeah right so if so just
because someone is diagnosed with
something doesn't mean they are a clear
and present danger to themselves or
anyone else so I do think for someone
like this or anyone the challenge here
is the red flag laws if if someone can
go and petition the government to file
some kind of claim against you take your
weapons here's the only thing I have
against it it's non-adversarial if
someone calls up a court and says I
believe Tim Poole is arrest for himself
for others they can serve me a notice
and then I'll have my lawyer answer it
and they can screw off because they need
probable cause proof and and due process
before they can deprive me of my rights
but what these red flag laws do is they
show up to your house and say don't
doesn't matter a judge said so no that
doesn't work that's that's not that's
not adversarial the accused needs a has
a right has a right to defend themselves
in due process but that also you're a
thousand percent right and I think it's
it's very disconcerting because we've
seen this abuse of process this lack of
due process and what we have seen
recently just saying the weaponization
of not only the political system but of
the judicial system you have activists
judges on the bench I don't care what
side you're on the point is it exists
and you also have to be careful who you
get in front of Idaho is a prosecutor
every time we're like oh geez you're
going to get in front of you know I knew
if I was going to try a case like in
Norwalk California they called it no
walk because the judges there were like
oh hell no they Dropped a Bomb on you
but then there was other ones it was
like guys nothing to see here folks we
can't even identify the individual here
has 17 aliases we don't know who they
are my cowboy fingerprint them and run
them through the system next thing you
know they're boom out the door and
they're out that's what's happening in
New York now so it all depends and where
you have these like weaponized like
District Attorney's offices you know
when I was at lad's office and even San
Francisco was more liberal it wasn't
like that but now we have like yes you
know this whole like Soros like funding
to all these different guys that are
very like weaponized activists and you
trace you follow the money you see who's
supported who's made donations to them
and then you're the person that has an
accusation against you and you would
appear in front of that judge or you
appear in front of that D.A you know
with the case it's it's gotten very
complicated put it that way it will also
price out people who are poorer right
because they can't afford good legal
counsel
the public defender's office but there's
some great public defenders out there
God bless you know tried a lot of cases
but that's uh that's roulette yeah
that's roulette you never know what
you're gonna get you think there's a way
to balance out the justice system like
judiciously with accorded judges I think
having one judge with all that power
like you're explaining they can they can
fall and also lifetime appointments is
another situation with some of them with
the federal judges and whatnot so it's
it's pretty scary because those people
get entrenched in there and they're you
know they have these different you know
mission objectives you know like before
we so say that you know court of appeals
the ninth Circuit Court of Appeal was
like where all like justice went to die
because they just had such an activist
agenda and then Trump started reporting
some other judges there to like balance
it out so people actually listen to the
cases versus just like rubber stamping
no buy thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become member over at timcast.com
for uncensored members only shows
exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time